I am pumped to welcome to Ford
world-class poker Champion
best-selling author of the book in my
hand die with zero getting all you can
from your money and your life hedge fund
manager epic investor Bill Perkins
welcome to forward bill
thank you thanks for having me I'm glad
to be here yeah so you you tell the
story too which I I laughed out loud so
your boss tells you look uh you're doing
it wrong you should not be trying to
scrimp and save you know a thousand
bucks if you're here to make a fortune
and you're like oh yeah you're right so
you start spending too much uh and then
you fall asleep at your station and get
fired
yeah this is another job but yeah
and but then you end up switching to uh
another job as a broker which is not
what you precisely want to do
um but that ends up leading you to a
role in Houston Texas where you are now
uh right and there are a lot of people
that might have hesitated about moving
to Houston from New York especially if
they wanted to work in you know training
because like oh you know like all the
action is in New York but then you
looked at it and said oh like like sure
I'll make this move uh and uh there was
like there were a couple of principles
in there uh where in your book you talk
about trying to be bold when you're
young uh and think about what you have
to lose because a lot of people
over emphasize what they might be giving
up and underestimate what they might be
gaining by writing a decision right they
don't look at the opportunity cost right
like of of the cost of inaction and and
I was one of those people that was like
I'm never moving south on a Mason-Dixon
Line like what the hell never go to
Texas like Texas was like rednecks and
racists and cowboys and you know I had
the stereotypical image largely informed
from uh past and TV right and you know I
didn't really know what Texas was like I
hadn't been there but you know I was I
was like I had the Texas of the 60s in
my head you know and so not not the
Texas that it was when I moved down
there but fortunately for me
I was so passionate about uh becoming a
Trader and and wanting to do it and and
this kind of like arrogant belief that I
could do it that I would have moved to
Siberia I would have went anywhere I was
like what's the worst that can happen
you know I mean if they get me they get
me you know this and I and I made the
move and and luckily I had that attitude
about it uh to do it and you know as I
look at other people in different
careers I see people like oh there's
this job and you can move here and
they're like I don't know I don't know
anybody there I'd have to move here Etc
and a lot of jobs or opportunities go
unfilled not necessarily that people
can't do it but they're not willing to
take the emotional risk of moving right
uh meeting new friends that that that
friction right and so they they stay in
a situation that may be less than ideal
or even painful like I say one of my
sayings is people will avoid paying to
live in misery and I'm not saying
everybody's a misery that doesn't move
but you know some gradient of that
happens
with that fear yeah you talk about a
sales clerk who doesn't like her job and
you're like hey you need to leave
because the fact is you could get
another job you don't like you know
immediately yeah
exactly yeah and and that that rang true
to me uh a lot of and so the the book
has different guidance for people at
different life stages and for young
people uh it's around trying to
hone in on what you can gain from taking
action as opposed to what you might lose
and taking more risks when you have less
to lose like be bolder when you you have
fewer responsibilities
yeah the downside is is right like you
know at the end of the day when I was
like scrimping and saving and and the
risk of the floor is like I could have
got a job literally at a fast food
restaurant and got paid more right like
they purposely pay you low because of
the opportunity set that's there and
you're gonna go make right and so going
going you know and it's like could I
could have been a waiter I could have
done any things like I was always going
to survive
uh you know survival wasn't an issue it
was just my ego of what was I willing to
do it when I fell down right and so I
should have been taking you know Max Max
risk in certain areas of my life I did
in certain areas I didn't you know in
terms of like emotional risk or taking a
travel or Etc like I could have got
another job as a screen clerk who
climbed the ranks easily like I was one
of the best screen clerks there ever
were I'm gonna say that I'm just gonna
say that you know like so like uh you
know I missed out right I missed out on
on that something that can't replace
that period of my life has died that
season is gone and it is now either you
know I I don't either don't have the
aptitude or the attitude to go do it
that way now
so you moved to Houston Texas and become
an energy Trader and end up being very
successful one of the big principles of
the book is around trying to figure out
what your uh life experience money
trade-offs are when you're on autopilot
and you're just like hey I got good at
this thing this thing produces money I'm
going to keep money when money becomes
the goal and not the tool to fulfill
your life you just keep going on
autopilot right the purpose it's like I
always tell people like Hammers and saws
you can like make the best Hammers and
saws but that's not the goal the goal is
to build a house but some people get
stuck just accumulating Amazons Amazon
so the money is a tool to to enhance
your life not the other way around and
so I think I think um even even at all
income levels right
you know people need to get to the
concept of enough and to know enough you
have to get off on a pilot like what do
I what experiences do I want in my life
what things are going to fulfill me
right uh and then once you have that you
know exactly how much money you need
yeah you talk too about time with your
kids and you're you're a parent you've
got two girls right
right I've got two boys
um and that itself also is like a scarce
resource or a trade-off where if you
don't spend time with your kids during a
certain
year like you don't get that year back
uh and and so there's also like an
investment in that regard it's like and
you might think to yourself oh I need to
make this money so that I can provide
for my family but
spending time with your kids actually is
an investment in them as well that in
some ways might be as or more important
and one of the things I love about you
and your approach to things like You're
so hyper rational about everything
where and we'll talk a little bit about
this where you don't stop with this book
you actually have produced a couple of
apps to help people optimize their time
money trade-offs but it instinctively
made sense to me that if you're spending
all your time and you make this point in
the book if you spend all your time
making money for the family and none of
your time actually with your family like
time spent with the family would have a
much higher return
for the child uh that then like another
couple bucks in a lot of situations
right if you look at money as a tool to
fulfill you right like it's basically a
tool fulfillment the first the first
level is survival right and then after
that we're operating on a want basis not
a need basis so once the needs debate uh
met we're operating on a want basis
and one of the things that your kids
want uh whether they consciously or or
or unconsciously is time with you
memories with you moments with you and
so piling an extra million dollars on it
but taking away that time from you is
basically giving them something useless
right what they want is time with you
right and I'm not saying I have the
answer to the the optimal balance right
like it's it's it's it's almost an
intractable problem but like these are
the things we need to think about uh so
that we get more close to the optimal
solution of balancing time with kids or
family members or loved ones or or what
have you yeah there was a lot of wisdom
in your book too about different life
stages where after you made some money
being a good grandson you give your
grandma ten thousand dollars uh and then
she doesn't do anything with it uh and
turns around and it gives you like a
sweater yeah yeah exactly sweater my mom
corrected me she also gave my daughter
like a chain like a small chain but like
it really hit home that uh you know the
utility of money changes as you age it
really becomes you know useless because
the number of activities that either you
enjoy doing or can do declines right
like and and this is just a natural
thing and I used to think oh not me I'm
going to be swinging from the
chandeliers in the club when I'm 70 you
know what I mean and I look at my
grandparents I'm like oh who am I
kidding like these are my ancestors this
is the way my even my dad you know who
was kind of kind of out there and you
know they just
they just shift into gears and so uh you
know the the the wealth planners or life
planners say you know there's the Go-Go
years uh the slow go years and the no-go
years and that's pretty much true for
universally true for everyone and so
those uh you know I call them Chuck E
cheese tokens that those dollars you
have the the the Chuck E cheese tokens
for partying or ski trips or doing this
whatever they expire right as you age
and they become useless and what I mean
is is that
certain amount of your money just
becomes useless to you it's not it's not
it's not it doesn't fulfill you the same
way it could have or at least the
activities that fulfill you start to
disappear
[Music]
foreign